hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
as you can see from the title and what
you're seeing on screen we're going to
be going
over all 100 tiers of the year 4 season
2 battle pass i have yet to see any of
these tiers myself so i'll be very
intrigued
but just judging from the bottom right
it seems that if you buy the premium
pass you will get a 10
bonus to battle points which is
something that they haven't done before
with the pass pass
and it seems like at the top it's also
again a very simple 300 of those points
to get to the each rank and just
remember if you're new to the game
that also at around here there is a 100
there's 150 that you can get just by
doing the dailies
so that is an easy easy amount of points
just from doing a couple dailies you do
that a couple times a day like you do
a couple games with the dailies you'll
be getting ranks no problem there should
be no reason why you're not getting tier
100
as we have tons of time to do this and
we have 97 days
that's a lot of time to do this i just
realized that's way higher than before
but going off with tier one we have the
horcos phantom set
this is the idol effect the e-mode
effect and the execution effect for
every single character so right out the
gate you get it for everybody every
character everything
this is some interesting stuff about the
horcos they didn't exactly explain
who these guys were too much but i was
still genuinely curious as
how this is going to fit with the story
apparently there's some type of group or
cult from what i remember so i'm very
curious to see what the hell is going on
with this
here's the ten percent battle points
boost if you do the premium pass
then you get the meridian of horco set
this the zonhu weapon right out the gate
i believe this is actually switched a
lot of the newer characters are getting
their weapons first as
as suppose i believe zhang who got his
weapon a tier 96 from
last season so definitely way better
than before because it took a while to
get zhang who's stuff
you see the scavenger crate you see the
shield big action actually a really big
fan of this emblem personally although i
do remember there being one at tier 100
though
so there's this we also have the kensei
emblem horcos aether this is for the
samurai only at this current moment but
there's probably going to be a lot more
in the other
factions later in the past get an xp
boost
you get a nice horcos defender color
already perfectly on
centurion here i think it's it seems to
be like a dark blue and a light blue
with a little bit of white
i can see this fitting with some of my
characters that i have but not too many
of them
we have the paint pattern the horicos
arcana you can see it on highlanders
shoulders and arms there
it's not too bad i feel like with a lot
better colors other than the default
colors that look a lot better
so there's that yarn gets his weapon at
tier vii
another xp boost there's also the battle
outfit horcos crystals this is going to
be for the knights specifically but
obviously this is for every single
character just
depending on when the faction gets it in
the past not too bad
i don't really know if i'm gonna like
use the emblem too much that
it comes with but i think the color
scheme is really nice it can fit with a
lot of nice colors that
some people decide to use at tier nine
we have the horcos aether for the
samurai
so that's already already there we got
hito kiri's at tier nine
really nice looking weapon also a
personal favorite of mine we have the
new embossing
called horco's crest it's kind of hard
to see on zon who here not really doing
it justice tiandi is a lot better shown
for this
but it's got this nice little serpent
going around the sword
personally not really too big of a fan
i'm not really sure how that fits into
any of my stuff but
maybe it'll fit somewhere we have the we
have the 500 steela tier 11
and the 250 salvage as well at tier 11.
we have the horcos attacker outfit which
uh
sorry the attacker color it's got this
orange and yellow scheme to it
personally i think this is a lot better
than the defender outfit i think this
can go with a lot of the
more characters that i have i like to
have a lot of really cool attacker
looking outfits for characters
and i think this orange and yellow is
gonna fit even on neutra right away like
this actually looks really sick with her
i could definitely combo that with some
gold weapons especially with the new
ones really sick
you have the hardcore's crystals for jj
of course with the wool in it
accompanying him you have the horcas
champion the
neutral color scheme as well so there is
it seems to be a
attacker color defender color and a
neutral color this one's for the samurai
specifically
not not really too bad it i really am
not really seeing where the color's
popping out too much it's just really a
brown and a white not too big of a fan
there
blackprior finally gets his weapons out
of tier 14 and my absolute favorite
weapon set out of this entire pass
and i definitely will hold myself to
that shaman gets hers at 17.
you also get the horgos crystals battle
outfit for the samurai 18
500 salvage at 16 and some 250 steel
at 15. there's also the new horcos
aether uh
three emblem which we haven't seen yet
in the past but this is for the knights
at the moment
and it's not too bad i don't once again
obviously this goes with some people's
builds
i think this could maybe fit if you
paired this emblem with like the nobushi
like cat mask i think that'd be really
nice to
gotta have both going at the same time
also the
the vikings got the horcos arcana paint
pattern three
so there's that as well moving on to 19
we got 500 steel we have
our amusha set also at tier 20.
the wu woven have horco's arcana 2 paint
pattern with the horcos epitome
gladiator symbol here of course
accompanied with the other knights
eh not really a big fan of emblems too
much they've never really been
too cool in my opinion but i guess that
could work an xp boosted 23 with the
horco's crystal battle outfit for the
vikings this time
also a tier 23 highlander gets his
weapon set at tier 24
we also have gladiators at tier 27
accompanied with a scavenger crate
the harco's aether one for the vikings
three days of champion status and one xp
boost for this section of the pass
on page seven we have the horcos crest
embossing for the samurai
250 salvage 500 steel we also have the
trophy head for aramusha
this isn't in oh wait this is new hold
on a second
hold on i'm really dumb i haven't seen
this yet
so it seems like a totally different
totally different sword and a totally
different i think that's the commander's
head
if i could be wrong but i do believe
that's the commander sword and the
commander's head from the breach game
modes
so that's a little spicy interesting
so the samurai are using the commander's
head i don't know if everybody's using
the commander's head i think it'd be
kind of weird if the knights
had their own commander's head we'll
probably see later in the past
we see shinobi's weapon at tier 31 with
the paint pattern horcos arcana for the
women at 30.
nothing really too crazy in this one
besides this part
then we get centurion's weapon at 34.
jj's at 37 accompanied of course with
250 steel at the top at 38 and 500
salvage at 36
horco's either two for the woven the
neutral color for the vikings of 35
and the knights version of the trophy
head and they also
use the same [ __ ] head that
isn't that their commander's head
what i'm so confused that's their own
commander's head right
because that's the that's the knight
what
okay whatever and you know what it's not
my place
there's probably a reason for it at tier
39 we have the
uh knights version of the attacker
colors at 40 we got the xp boost 41
we got the warlord set i don't know why
in the picture the sword looks bigger
than the shield
the shield looks smaller because it's
clearly wrong but this is a
absolutely amazing set if you're a
warlord player be especially happy with
this
then we get to the viking version of
this e-mode at 43
so once again another five after the
nights you already get the point i don't
need to show this more
of course the tier 48 we get the wool in
version of this at
i know the next five tiers after horcos
arcana 2 for the samurai
the epitome symbol for the vikings we
have the defender colors for the samurai
500 steel and shigoki gets to get his
weapon set
a tier at page 11 my apologies we get
the conqueror weapon
we also have the aether one for the
knights scavenger crate
some salvage and a couple xp boosts at
12 we have the shaolin weapon set
accompanied with the valkyrie weapon set
really nice looking shield on hers
we have the embossing house of meyer
that actually doesn't look that bad i
actually kind of like that personally
it was way better looking at her cape
but then it disappeared we also got 500
steel and 250 salvage not too
bad tier 59 we got the gladiator symbol
or accompanied of course by the knights
with aether ii
nobushi also gets her weapon set and
then the clans of falconheim
also coming in for all 26 characters at
tier 63 so
a lot of embossing we've been getting in
this page page 14 we get lawbringer's
weapon
with the legions of ashfield as an
embossing for all 26 heroes of course
accompanied by 500 and then another 250
steel so
getting a lot of steel in this pass
surprisingly i've been seeing a lot of
that
lucia at tier 71 with her weapon the
woolen from the east
embossing as well for all 26 heroes with
a 500 salvage
and then the other stuff that we've seen
before tier 74 berserker's weapon
tier 77 is a rochi's weapon we also see
a scavenger crate the horcos epitome
boost and a 500 steel it's your 79 we
get the horcos arcana one
peacekeeper gets her weapon set at tier
80 accompanied by
500 salvage the horcos theorium battle
outfits which seems to be totally
new now i don't remember seeing this
earlier in the past so a nice looking
battle outfit if you don't like the
colors i would uh
especially enjoy the symbol honestly if
you want to get that horco's vibe going
we also get the horcos fealty which is a
ornament for all the samurai currently
not too bad uh i don't think this is
going to fit on like 90 percent of the
characters but
i think it looks nice just based off the
three we've seen this doesn't fit at all
at tier 88 we also got the same thing
for the knights also accompanied by the
exact same battle outfit
raider gets his weapon at 87 with tiandi
getting his
84 of course with the aether 3 and some
salvage
at 89 we get some more steel 90 is
kensei's weapon set a really nice look
of black and gold
they will then of course get their
accompanied battle outfits and
ornament of course we already have
talked about this at tier 96 the vikings
get theirs with the battle outfits and
the ornament
as well as warden getting the weapons
set at tier 95 and i believe the very
last weapon
in the battle pass until you know the
next season because i think this is the
highest it goes because i think after is
the executions
with some 500 salvage and 250 steel
coming down to the very last page we
have the tier 100 ornament
which are the tier 100 reward apologies
which
is the new shield i don't actually they
don't give names to shields they should
really start giving names to these
shields
this is really sick they also have the
seven days of champion status and then
the horcrux volcano three
accompanied by the horcos pharmacos
which i believe is the exact same
execution
for every character
that's poison okay so the vikings get
that
they start having a seizure so i believe
this is the exact same
as opposed to last season where we ended
up getting that
execution but it was different it was
more faction based this seems to be
every single one
getting the same execution and
personally i'm actually really cool with
this because this is a dope execution
i'd be extremely annoyed if
not all the characters got this i think
coming up to the character
walking up to them you know let's get
the perspective view
back over the knee pour some acid in
their face have them seize a bit i think
that's a really nice execution i think
that's definitely needed for every
character
and yeah that's the entire battle pass
i'd say that
this time around i think the shield is
[ __ ] amazing and i think it's totally
worth the tier 100
i think the executions are worth the
tier 100 i think a lot i think this
compared to the past
uh battle pass that we got i think this
is definitely an upgrade
should things change i would say you
know maybe a couple things like
scavenger crates being just a little you
know maybe a bit more scavenger crates
but
you know maybe that's just me some
people have always i've asked for more
steel but i think
i think what ubisoft did is instead of
taking the approach of adding more
specific steel to the like the tier so
instead of having 500 it's like a
thousand
they've added a lot more of the steel i
haven't done the calculations myself
but i might add in the comments down
below uh
the full totals of the salvage the steel
so if you want to check that out
i would highly recommend that if you
want to see the very very total amount
of stuff happening
so yeah that's the end of the pass boys
uh just let me know what you guys think
about this stuff in the comments below
like i said i think this stuff is really
sick it's gonna be super easy to climb
through this battle pass
i think this will probably be done i
probably predict getting this done in
like
two to three weeks personally if you
grind out hours and hours
so honestly there's that also look out
for the newest video there's two new
emotes and two new executions coming but
we'll talk about that in the next video
but it's always like to be if you do
enjoy guys subscribe if you're new
i covered the informational side of one
of the being the balance changes they
hear updates the patches and the leaks
if you want to be kept updated with
everything happening than the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update then please describe the channel
i guess take care of grace today enjoy
the event and everything else that comes
with this season
and peace out
[Music]
you